[Music]
[Applause]
talk to mike florio pro football talk
live co-host and his new book playmakers
is out
how the nfl really works and doesn't
it's uh in bookstores today can be
purchased online and it's uh
a close look at the past two decades of
the nfl one story at a time more than
100 stories in there guaranteed to upset
the nfl and mike florio joins us on the
program good luck with the book there
mike
[Laughter]
dan i hope that you enjoy my final
appearance on the program it's been a
fun ride
the drone is hovering outside my house
as i speak it's locked and loaded have
you heard from anybody in the nfl home
office about your book
yes i have and it was when we first
started
trying to get people to buy the book i
was told by someone with a very high
level position in the nfl that
there is a plan to purchase a
a supply of them for dissemination and
study in the hopes of i don't know
improving things or at least
understanding what this idiot in west
virginia is saying about them but
apparently there will be a box that is
sent to 345 park avenue at some point
unless the person was lying to me which
is entirely possible all right what did
pittsburgh do yesterday
hey well they they got
a placeholder potentially at quarterback
and the irony in all of this is that
five years ago the bears signed mike
glennon in free agency and we all
thought mike glennon is going to be
their quarterback in 2017 god save the
bears and then that was just the cover
so that they could draft mitchell
trubisky now playing the role of mike
glennon in pittsburgh in 2022
potentially is mitchell trubisky because
two years 14 million dollars for
trubisky
that screams out to me that they've got
something else in mind shirley trubisky
isn't the answer and maybe they'll go
forward with him if so it's a great
dollar for dollar deal sims and i were
talking about this earlier would you
rather pay trubisky 7 million a year or
kirk cousins 35 million a year is kirk
cousins five times better than mitchell
trubisky no he's not so it's a great
bargain for the steelers but it gives
them the ability if they choose in round
one with the 20th overall pick to take a
quarterback if there's a guy there they
really like or even trade up we've seen
them trade up for guys like troy
polamalu and san antonio holmes and
devon bush if there's a guy they really
like they're not going to tell us they
run a tight ship they keep their cards
close to the vest we didn't know they
were on trubisky that's just an example
of how they do things so they may not be
done but
the good news is if you're a steeler fan
you don't have to worry about mason
rudolph playing quarterback for the team
this year
i like the move because it doesn't cost
you anything and maybe if you look at
what he's done historically made the pro
bowl made the playoffs a couple of times
his one lost record i think he's what
eight or nine games over 500
he can be respectable there and he can
get coached up unlike matt nagy who
didn't like him you know he's got a
coach that will actually coach him up
and maybe make him better there in
pittsburgh well the challenge is always
this day when you have a new coach
with a player who
doesn't fit your system do you
say too bad figure out how to fit my
system or do you adjust your system to
fit the player naggy never adjusted the
system he tried to force trubisky to fit
it and look they went to the playoffs
twice with a great defense and a solid
supporting cast kind of like what he's
going to have in pittsburgh so if they
do have to go forward with trubisky
they're not going to come out and tell
us what they think of this incoming crop
of rookie quarterbacks if they decide
trubisky is the guy
they can be as good as they were last
year because trubisky right now is
better than ben roethlisberger was last
year because roethlisberger was a shell
of the guy he used to be he couldn't
move he had to get rid of the ball very
quickly trubisky has athleticism
and and if if you adapt your system to
suit his strengths and cover up his
weaknesses
he can win games for you yeah i agree
we normally don't focus on the jaguars
as a positive but it seemed like they
had a pretty good day yesterday how
would you sum up what the jags did
well one way to try to get yourself out
of a cycle of dysfunction is to spend
your way out of it and that's what the
jaguars are trying to do they are using
money to buy players to get people to
say hey that team really isn't a
complete and total mess right now but
when you look at the individual players
they got is pretty good now they may
have had to overspend see you want to
get to the point where you win the ties
where all things equal players want to
come play for you and someone else has
to outbid you to get that guy i think
the jaguars right now are in that mode
where they have to offer more than
others but when you look at what they've
done offensively they get brandon sherf
they add a couple of receivers and
christian kirk and zay jones
they have evan ingram who i think has
more potential than what he's shown with
the giants it's a one-year deal it's 9
million he gets to go back to the market
next year and maybe cash in if he has a
big year there's just a quiet confidence
that's emanating from these moves and
these guys are choosing to sign on for a
team that was a mess last year i think
they recognize there's potential with
the super bowl winning coach in doug
peterson a number one overall pick in
trevor lawrence urban meyer is gone
i think that that the jaguars
not they're going to be a playoff
contender right away but who knows we
wouldn't have said last year the bengals
are going to be a playoff contender if
we were talking about it in march
the jags loading up on defense here
uh what do you think of the moves or
chargers i should say
well all the charges it's incredible
look they're competing
not just with the other teams in the afc
west they're competing with the other
team in their own stadium
the rams of the defending champions the
banner and i don't know is the rams
banner going to be up when the chargers
are playing their home games either the
banner or the brackets that the banner
hangs on will be there as a reminder to
the chargers that the rams are the
current kings of the nfl so they get
their their answer to aaron donald
although khalil mack isn't what aaron
donald currently is once upon a time
they were neck and neck best defensive
player in the nfl they get there jaylen
ramsey and j.a.c jackson
they're doing what they have to do they
get some interior defensive line help
they get sebastian joseph day to change
locker rooms in the same stadium so i i
they are taking full advantage dan of
the fact that this is the last year
that they have justin herbert on the
slotted rookie contract which allows
them to overspend cap dollars in other
areas because next year they're going to
have to do that contract with justin
herbert this year they can go all out to
try to become a competitor a contender a
playoff team maybe a super bowl team
right away
the numbers on aaron rodgers are out so
you got
two years guaranteed you're talking
three years 150 million dollars
what do you do with davonte adams
well he says he's not going to play
under the franchise tag but what's he
going to do is he going to sit out all
year is he going to say no to 20 million
and not sit out it's 20 million dollars
for one year of football i i think that
you have to try to figure out a way to
get him to take a deal that he finds
acceptable and so far they haven't been
able to bridge that gap but if you have
to just wait him out if you just have to
hope he shows up i don't know why he
wouldn't show up at 20 million dollars
that is a lot to leave behind and a year
from now they could just tag him again
so i i think that
that yeah it's going to be a challenge
to sign into a long-term deal and one of
the problems with the packers is they
don't like to guarantee money beyond the
first year of a contract well if you're
going to get a guy with the franchise
tag whose first year salary is already
guaranteed at 20 million if you're going
to get him to sign a long-term deal you
better throw that structure out the
window the steelers did it last year
with tj watt the bengals haven't done it
yet and they need to the packers are
going to need to do it with devontae
adams
jordan love experiment over would you
trade him
i
would probably be inclined to keep him
around because his salary is so low he's
a lot cheaper than any backup you're
going to find he knows the system if
aaron rodgers gets injured he can step
right in and you never know what roger's
going to do after this year i haven't
seen the full details i want to see all
of the nuances of this contract to
understand how easy or difficult it will
be for aaron rodgers to retire after one
year i'm curious is he making a two-year
commitment to the packers or is it year
to year if it's year to year i need
jordan love there in the event that
aaron rodgers decides to retire after
the 2022 season so
i think i hold on to him for now
uh and and they've got you know they've
got some investment in the idea that
this guy's going to turn into a player
they traded up in round one to get him i
feel bad for him he's the only one in
this drama in green bay i feel bad for
because he's the only one that got inven
involuntarily sucked into it by getting
drafted by the packers because surely he
wouldn't have signed up to be
the guy who pisses off aaron rodgers and
sparks multiple mvp campaigns from one
of the best quarterbacks in the history
of the game he's mike florio pro
football talk live co-host and his new
book playmakers is officially out tom
brady's dad said that the media sort of
forced tom into retirement here
wow
do you take credit for that any do
should we take credit for that
does tom brady call his wife the media
around the house i mean i feel like it
was gisele that was pushing and pushing
him to finally walk away there were
shots of her in the suite during that
playoff loss to the rams when they were
down 27-3 and she just seemed like
somebody who wasn't all that upset that
they were down and kind of happy that
this thing's finally going to be over
and she's been trying for five years to
get him to walk away
i don't know i don't understand it i
mean he started talking about coming
back six days after he announced his
retirement no one pushed him into this
maybe he needed to say okay i retire and
now i'm going to take some time to think
about my decision and then he decides to
unretire but it's nobody's fault but his
own if he wanted to i mean it all came
out of the blue dan he had said all year
long he's playing through 2022
this idea that he may retire was
stunning to me it went against
everything he had ever said he's going
to play until he's 45 that's through
next year so that i don't think anyone
was pressuring him or
it was not a story it wasn't an issue it
all came from him so i i don't i don't
buy that at all and uh
you know get ready because tom brady's
now brett favre and it's going to be
every year every year every year until
he finally calls it quits okay let's uh
recap the bet you had a bet with paulie
now i'm gonna give you credit you said
brady was coming back but you said
you said
that you would bet a pie to the face
that brady would be the week one starter
in san francisco i did okay i did did
you lose the bet
well i i've tried to negotiate something
with paulie i thought he was talking to
his lawyers about this i've been waiting
to get the facts from the law offices of
whoever he has hired uh to to come to a
conclusion here because i think he was
adamant on the fact that brady's not
coming back
did you win the bet
uh i've talked to my people dan and we
believe our camp believes that we won
the bet outright okay we're using
semantics over smarts okay
yes yeah if i could be an impartial
observer here wouldn't we have to wait
until week one to find out who won the
bet okay yes
thank you it's just
you know effort of fairness here i think
we have to wait week one to see who's
starting so you are you team florida wow
no i'm team
fairness i'm team fairness fairness yes
uh this is what it sounded like a couple
of weeks ago
i think he's coming back
i just think he's trying to find a way
out of tampa are you willing to bet on
that
how much like a pie to the face
oh a pie to the face i mean part of the
face is nothing it depends i mean unless
it's like you know an acid pie no no
of your choice anybody want to take
florio up on a pie to the face paulie
paulie will say that brady does not uh
not come back just the niners we're
talking right just the niners i'll do it
okay so pie to the face florio wait week
one niners if he's on
the niners who takes a pie to the face
paulie does paul paulie does and if he's
not on the niners and i take the pie to
me yes
okay you come on the show and maybe your
wife can administer or uh chris sims
could administer apply to the that's it
paulie that's a walk-off like larry bird
in the three-point shooting contest he's
uh you name it super bowl three
seton's right
seton's right
week one
is the trigger here paulie did say just
the nighters paulie did squeeze in just
the night i know okay how about this the
monday after week one
you'll pay up if tom brady is still yeah
okay if he's not on the niners week one
yes i will pay up then okay yes paul dan
as the winner of the bet i'd like to
suggest a an option for mike floyd
mike as uh we've been doing this for a
long time with pius in the face i'll
prepare this for you as an offer on the
table now or you could take dan's offer
you could have someone anyone you choose
hit you with the pie of your choice
in the month of march oh an off season
pop off season pie which is easy that's
easy living okay okay or a lemon
meringue pie in september the heat of
west virginia
lemon meringue
yes
um if i can just say the lemon meringue
pie as a pie veteran yeah that's the one
that i had it on my face for about five
minutes while the segment ended and had
a sunburn for the next two weeks it
burned the crap out of my skin an expert
witness there the lemon so
oh i just wanted to throw that in there
mike mike do you want an off season pie
or would you rather roll the dice and we
would do that monday after the first
weekend of nfl action now now now so the
pie would be completely of my own
recipe my own choosing it can be i would
have to prove it i would have to approve
it well because the the typical pie to
the face is just a bunch of whipped
cream in a pie pan
we like to throw in strawberries or
raspberries or blueberries crust in
there it has to be a pie that you can
eat i'll let it ride and i'll take the
sunburn from the
lemon meringue pie uh by the way deshawn
watson is he going to cleveland today
to talk to you they're gonna they're
they're going to houston to meet him but
dan he's got you mentioned he's going to
be questioned today for the first time
ever about these 22 civil lawsuits by
tony busby who's going to be very
aggressive and as a lawyer former lawyer
recovering lawyer escaped lawyer i'm not
comfortable with the idea that last
night desean watson's meeting with the
saints and panthers i want him relaxing
i want him getting a good night's sleep
he's in for a tough day today of being
interrogated for hours about what he did
and didn't do with these people who have
sued him for sexual misconduct but i
don't want him distracted by his next
football team but does he have to answer
the questions can he plead the fifth in
a civil lawsuit or a deposition
he was cleared on friday no criminal
charges and his lawyer has said once we
get past the grand jury if he's not
charged he will answer the question so
he's going to answer the question it's
going to be a long day and is there a
video of this mike that
i think there will be video there'll be
video there'll be a transcript now it
may not be publicly available but if i'm
interested in desean watson i'm talking
to his lawyers now saying look i want to
see this transcript i want to watch this
video before i make a final decision and
i know of at least one potentially
interested team that won't do anything
until it knows how today goes so i'm not
real comfortable with him being
distracted by this but the browns are in
i don't know how baker mayfield is going
to feel about it but the browns are
definitely in
and we don't even know what the
commissioner is going to do they they
might look at this as time served by him
not playing last year but i don't i
don't know if the commissioner is
going to factor that in in his
potential punishment here's what i think
the nfl has learned over the years as
chronicled by several of the essays and
playmakers the nfl has learned to never
do anything until it has to
right yeah you can't make a mistake if
you don't do anything so
there's a chance
that they won't do anything until the
civil cases are resolved if he settles
them maybe he gets suspended if he loses
at trial on one or more of these claims
maybe he gets suspended but dan if he
fights them all the way through to a
verdict and he wins all 22 of these if
22 boxes are checked in his favor
on the verdict form how do you how do
you suspend him then how do you justify
it he was never charged he was never
arrested he was never even found
responsible under the very low standard
of preponderance to the evidence 51 49
actually 50.1 49.9 it's a little bit no
he's not responsible so so why would you
suspend him so
the league has learned to wait it won't
surprise me if the league does nothing
at all until after the civil cases are
gone but let's say he writes a check and
it all goes away
then the commissioner
won't punish him could could now there
was some belief last year because the
dolphins were willing to trade for him
the dolphins and the panthers were
willing to trade for before the trade
deadline the panthers were fine with
none of the legal issues being resolved
criminal or civil but we'll take him but
he wouldn't waive the no trade clause
for carolina last year he would waive it
for miami miami owner stephen ross
wanted all 22 cases settled my
understanding is that dolphins believed
that he was going to get suspended
roughly six games if he had settled
those cases so that's what miami
believed now the nfl keeps the cards
close to the vest i don't know if they
just made a guess but i think if he
settles he's far more susceptible i just
don't know how you justify suspending
him if he does fight this all the way
and a jury decides he didn't do anything
that rises to the level of violating
someone else's rights thank you buddy
good luck with the book he's mike florio
pro football talk live co-host and the
new book is called playmakers thank you
mike thanks dan appreciate it play of
the day up next and your phone calls